à combien croyez-vous qu'il venait de
pâte à puce le vôtre aux échos notez
bien sur vos droits
moi j'adore votre cube
attention ils ont manqué
[Musique]
et reviendra plus du tout je n'ai vu une
belle chez la marchande
[Musique]
malheureusement ma tirelire évident il
épate a plus de vide renvoie les lourds
pour me l'acheter je suis bien triste et
riche que je vais sans doute on est
malade attacker une lettre pour toi
merci de kiev site en anglais en anglais
et patachou pas ta vie tu veux n'évite
pas d'accord avoue une réponse anglais
je n'y comprends rien j'aime l'idée elle
vient d'amérique pataca tu connais
quelques uns en amérique
non mais ils ne connaissent que ça y est
tu parles en baisse yes moustapha ka
c'est vrai qu'ils parlent anglais
il allait plus la lettre
chère mademoiselle papac nous avons
appris quand vous étiez la plus belle de
tous et nous vous invitons à participer
aux gros concours de beauté
international qui aura lieu à hollywood
très prochaine du livre où que vous
soyez prêt élégant avec toute notre
admiration signé les brothers ce break
voilà quel honneur
pourquoi pleures tu pourquoi on va vider
notre tirelire et tu sauras la plus
belle
c'est réussi
je vais avoir une belle robe ne suis la
plus belle c'est en français comme en
anglais
je suis très inquiet vous le faites pas
de bruit
vous n'êtes pas malade au moins non non
tout va bien nous avons reçu une lettre
en anglais en or d'un sac à papier je
peux jeter un coup d'oeil je parle très
bien l'anglais mais bien sûr monsieur
bougon chère mademoiselle grâce au
disque de la sniffe compagnie vous
apprendrez l'anglais en vain le son ce
qui vous permettrait de comprendre cette
lettre dont la traduction vous est donné
au dos c'est ce qu'il ya d'écrit
mais oui d'ailleurs regardez au patac
heures s'est moqué de nous pour avoir
une europe noire
nous allons nous venger
[Musique]
c'est la pub et qui sera épuisée je te
ra pas toi ta lettre elle est écrite en
français de l'autre côté de la feuille
regarde pour te punir tu feras la
vaisselle et le ménage pendant une
semaine et ta belle robe neuve on va la
donner à patates a aussi justement élira
sautoir ou pour faire la vaisselle en
plus belle c'est moi
[Musique]
ou aa alors toutes deux chars d'assaut
combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de pas
taper je ne voterons pékin comptait bien
sur vos droits
après ils nous manquent
[Musique]